my feeling about short fiction though is
complicated and I think that anytime
historically when the New Yorkers
fiction has been perceived as or as
truly strong there are probably two or
three or four writers who are really
floating the boat because of their
mastery of short fiction this was
certainly true and say the 60s and 70s
when Cheever Updike Donald Barthelme and
I'm leaving on leaving people out
that's who you remember you remember
over time the masterful work the best
work it's not a question of less of it
that's not true what's the question is
who do you regard in a given moment as a
master of the short story and the
problem is I think a lot of writers
graduate out of short fiction they write
them in youth in their 20s and then they
stop and it is unusual for the pattern
to be otherwise Jhumpa Lahiri who's now
probably 40 is unusual much more
ordinary pattern is Philip Roth he
writes goodbye Columbus their short
stories that gained him some notoriety
and he moves on it is extremely unusual
to have a career like John Cheever and
there in which you're writing short
stories from the beginning to the end of
your writing life and Alice Monroe is
another unusual one I can't really think
of too many fiction writers of middle
age and younger where the short story
plays the the dominant role maybe George
Saunders be one but it's unusual
first of all I think there are enough of
them had at a high enough level that in
fact I find myself reading them with
enormous enjoyment pleasure intrigue all
the rest you know when you're always and
being an editor is about hope and we
come out every week it's like asking a
baseball manager if you happen to lose
three games nor why do you keep playing
because there's the next day and I you
know I think American fiction is is in a
state of real strength the american
short-story you have to keep looking and
you have to keep encouraging writers
sometimes who are farther along to to
write stories and sometimes that works
it certainly works with the El
Doctorow's you know obviously not in the
beginning of his career and also hope
that you discover younger writers in the
beginning when they are writing short
stories that are strong and that's
happened over and over and over again we
hold in our minds editors readers our
contemporaries a an ideal of a tribal
literary discussion we somehow have the
faint notion that somewhere some just
before our time that there existed
magazines and books that everybody read
every one meaning every one of our
extended circles read and then discussed
at dinner I think to some extent this
was always romanticized but it is true
that the distractions of the world now
are more various greater number and more
diverse look at popular music popular
music even when I was growing up there
was there were central hit making radio
stations that everybody listened to in
the car at home and then as a result of
what you liked
what you didn't like that's how you
bought these things called albums
through these large square things and
you would go to each a Corvettes and for
399 you'd buy them okay and then that
song would go up the charts down the
charts and so on now music is consumed
in an entirely radically niched way and
even a way of making sense of it like on
the back page of Rolling Stone there are
15 different charts college radio chart
this chart but that doesn't even begin
to tell the story of the way music is
consumed radically differently than the
way it was some time ago I think
similarly with books we are kidding
ourselves if we think that everybody's
reading the same thing especially in
serious fiction at the same time I think
the New Yorker can make an attempt by
putting forward this story or that's to
where on a given week and hope for the
best but it was always a rare thing that
everybody was talking about JD
Salinger's Franny or Zooey or what have
you that's a rare thing when everybody
coalesce is around a piece of fiction at
a given moment
it really is